yo digo que hay que aprender del vino
el vino permanece durante varios meses a
niveles muy bajos de luz
y gradualmente he llevado una
iluminación más alta de lo contrario si
es expuesto repentinamente a la luz las
levaduras no están acostumbradas y se
echan a perder en lugar de convertirse
en vino se convierten en vinagre
a veces nos enojamos o nos frustramos
porque lo que queremos no lo tenemos ya
o las cosas no son lo que queremos ya se
nos olvida que en la vida todo requiere
de un proceso
estamos viviendo tiempos en lo que todo
es inmediato hoy las cosas son
instantáneas son fugaces y las
generaciones que vienen detrás de
nosotros están creciendo pensando eso
que todo podemos tenerlo de inmediato si
tengo hambre si quiero ver una película
todavía no está en el cine yo ya gaby
incluso citas románticas
se nos está olvidando que en la vida se
requiere mucho más que eso que las cosas
que realmente valen la pena requieren
más esfuerzo y no tan solo deslizar un
dedo
soy alma blanco soy comunicóloga
comediante locutora creadora del blog el
alma de los tacos de un amor genuino por
los tacos
yo voy como tacos los grabó y le digo a
la gente coman
entonces básicamente vivo de lo que me
apasiona las risas y la comida y de un
carente miedo al colesterol
y en este carrera yo aprendí que no tan
solo importa el destino es importante
que disfrutemos este viaje ten metas
enamórate de ellas enfócate en ellas
pero disfruta el proceso la próxima vez
que salgan de la ciudad piensen en esto
nuestro viaje empieza desde que abrimos
la maleta y andamos pasando hay un tazón
y las chanclas
no nos vamos con los ojos cerrados lo
que no me importa nada no me voy a tomar
ninguna el fin el avión no lo cancún
quiero que no
nuestro viaje comienza desde que incluso
tenemos en la mente e ir a cancún y lo
vas planeando y de eso se trata la vida
de que vivas este proceso
pero que lo vivas de verdad y aquí todo
el santa anita sus tareas
pero para descubrir esto tuvieron que
pasar muchas cosas para descubrir eso
que te apasiona y eso que te mueve y eso
que te hace vibrar bonito tienen que
pasar muchas cosas estudié la
licenciatura en educación preescolar
preescolar durante cinco semestres y un
día me di cuenta que eso no era lo mío
porque me quería alburear a los niños
y quería agarrar los papas de los
cabellos y decirles no señora la
educación no termina ni empieza en el
kinder usted tiene que seguirla en su
casa entonces no podía yo
y cuando me armé de valor y fui y le
dije a mi mamá que yo ya no quería
estudiar eso nunca se me va a olvidar lo
que mi mamá me contestó aquella noche yo
iba con todo el miedo del mundo
esperando que volara la chancla en
llamas
y cuando le dije que ya no quería ir a
la normal ella me dijo ya no vayas
entonces yo llego con la chancla de que
cit
y yo le dije no me vas a regañar tantito
y ella me contestó no si quieres vender
elotes vende lotes pero que sean los
mejores elotes del mundo
esta noche mi mamá me enseñó que podemos
ser quienes queramos en esta vida pero
siempre dando lo mejor de nosotros que
podemos ser lo que queramos pero no
podemos ser felices si no hacemos lo que
nos gusta
entonces dejé esa carrera yo quería
estudiar comunicación y toda la gente me
decía te vas a morir de hambre y yo les
contestaba no me importa vivir abajo de
un puente pero feliz vivo bajo el puente
del 1 no entonces
estudia comunicación desde esa carrera y
descubrir también que es la mejor
decisión que pudo haber tomado en la
vida se los puedo decir hoy me llevo
mucho tiempo tuvieron que pasar muchas
cosas yo soy locutora desde que tengo 17
años y quería y quiero trabajar en eso
por el resto de mis días pero pasaron
muchas cosas yo dejé nuevo laredo porque
soy originaria de aquí y me fui a vivir
a monterrey en busca de mejores
oportunidades pero no llegas de que ya
llegué hasta la locutora fui mesera y
tuve que tener este trabajo para
mantenerme en este sueño en la búsqueda
de mis sueños limpiaba mesas limpiaba
baños pisos
y bien esta imagen constantemente a mí
cuando me pongo crema en las manos
porque pues obviamente la niña no hacía
nada nada más hablaba y cuando ya tuve
que trabajar y hacía frío y todo el día
tenemos que estar lavando platos y entre
los químicos y el jabón y todo eso mis
manos están súper coloradas y partidas
entonces era muy difícil para mí ya ni
me quería ni bañar porque alguna
pero yo estaba feliz porque tenía un
trabajo y estaba en búsqueda de mi sueño
y podía platicar con gente diferente
todos los días luego ya llegaba a mi
casa y lloraba en posición fetal
poniendo me creo a twitter
y me preguntaba por qué estoy haciendo
esto porque me estoy haciendo esto y yo
mucho tiempo creí que el haber sido
mesera me había ayudado a mantenerme en
esta búsqueda pero hoy sé que fue ese
sueño lo que me ayudó porque muchas
veces no hubo nada para sostenerme más
que ese sueño
meses después descubrí la comedia
uno de los miedos más grandes de los
seres humanos es hacer el ridículo pero
cuando aprendes a reírte de ti mismo tu
vida cambia completamente dicen que
entre peor te baja te vaya abajo del
escenario mejor te va arriba yo no me
podía poner crema en donde me iba con
madre
y yo aprendí primero a reírme de mis
adversidades para después hacer reír al
mundo y esa es mi manera de ayudar esa
es mi manera de hacer reír a las
personas en medio de las adversidades
que tengan ese día que me ven y me
encanta cada que subo a un escenario yo
pienso que las cosas allá afuera están
super difíciles pero si yo ese día ya
hice reír aunque sea una persona yo
siento que ya gane
pasó el tiempo yo andaba repartiendo mi
demo cómo barajitas logró entrar a la
radio regiomontana y estaba feliz y
entonces empezó a aparecer la gente yo
siempre creí en ti yo sabía
yo también que es mi pasión también la
locución pues ya que estás adentro pasar
de un contacto no
y yo les decía no es que no fue así yo
llegué la crema no puede trabajar
y me decían no pero esto ya está ahí
para hacerte un contacto que webb a
andar así como tú
porque todo queremos ya hay que aprender
del vino y no andar le jugando al
vinagre
y yo no puedo darles la clave secreta
para triunfar mágicamente en la vida
porque no existe tal magia pero en este
camino yo descubrí tres cosas número uno
cae te hay que caerse y si no te estás
cayendo preocúpate por qué no estás
haciendo nada yo no hago caer si no me
muevo no entonces tienes que hacer cosas
permítete caerte a veces no está mal
estar mal y en todos los aspectos
psicológicamente no te estás castigando
porque un día no sabes qué hacer
permítete estar un martes a las tres de
la tarde en calzones desayunando
galletas saladas sin saber qué va a
pasar con tu vida
a mí me funcionó
cae tan profesionalmente yo tenía una
jefa que me hablaba y me decían no eres
chistosa y me colgaba
y si yo me hubiera ido a mi casa y ahora
que eso es cierto
pues no estaría aquí entonces cadete no
te rajes kite emocionalmente en este
recorrido o en este camino hacia lo que
yo quería me rompieron el corazón en 487
pedacitos mi ex decía que era bien
exagerada
y creo que nadie habla de los corazones
rotos al momento de emprender o al
momento de estar formando tu camino
profesional pero pasa y va a pasar y que
dice la gente hasta chiflada quiere
llamar la atención anda bien desocupada
porque no puedes llegar a tu trabajo con
la capacidad que tienen corazón roto
o si está bien templado
pero sucede y yo les digo permitan
caerse pero levántense
la segunda cosa es
agradecer
la base de la felicidad es estar
agradecidos dicen los psicólogos
recomiendan que tengamos un diario de la
gratitud donde cada noche apuntamos tres
cosas por las que ese día estamos
agradecidos y no quiero que vayan ir con
su diario de que dijo lemos no estoy
nadando en billetes ni en un yate ni en
mi mansión de ocho pisos no hay que
aprender a agradecer las cosas pequeñas
mi papá es el mejor contador de
historias que ustedes jamás van a
escuchar y si nosotros alguna vez
tuvimos una carencia no lo supimos
porque de niños él nos contaba historias
maravillosas de un poco de un trapeador
de las hojas de lo que fuera y él
siempre nos dice que nunca perdamos la
capacidad de asombrarnos porque el día
que pierdes esa capacidad lo habrás
perdido todo
entonces agradecen las cosas pequeñas
pero también hay que agradecer las cosas
malas que nos pasan porque nos están
permitiendo crecer yo lo veo como si
fuera un videojuego entonces cada que
algo malo te pasa y logras vencerlo es
como si avanzarás a otro nivel y te
dieran un arma nueva cada que siento que
hoy porque me pasa esto a mí como la voy
a hacer piensa wow me están dando la
oportunidad de crecer
y la tercera es regresar siento que hay
que regresarle un poquito a la vida de
todo lo que nos da a este mundo le hacen
falta más voluntarios y personas que
seamos menos indiferentes y más humanas
siento que al escuchar la palabra
voluntario no fue así como aquí y
sentimos que tenemos que dar un esfuerzo
enorme de nuestra parte pero no no es
necesario que te vayas a rescatar
delfines ciegos al atlántico
lo que te vayas a vivir a una montaña
descalzo sé que voy a ayudar a la gente
no
un buenos días aunque bonita te ves hoy
un cómo estás un se cayó a la señora en
nuestra nada se cayó la señora no se
cayó a la señora la grabó para subirlo
al facebook no se caiga la señora déjame
la ayudó
de eso se trata regresarle un poquito a
la vida de lo que nos da entonces estas
palabras caer agradecer y regresar
forman la palabra card
así lo veo yo que es carro en inglés
y me gusta verlo así para recordarme que
todos nos podemos subir a este carrito y
esto no garantiza que tu camino no va a
tener baches pero les aseguro que va a
ser más llevadero
no estamos esperando el mejor escenario
para hacer las cosas porque nunca va a
existir a veces estamos esperando cuando
tenga otro trabajo cuando tengo otra
casa cuando tengo otro vecino cuando
tengo otros papás no
haz las cosas ya un día yo escuchar y en
decir vale con lo que tengas y después
ves y de eso se trata de aventar t de
hacer las cosas ya en este momento
porque tú lo sientes yo trabajé muchos
años sin que se me diera un peso y ahora
lo pienso y es una experiencia
invaluable la que me dieron esos años
que no puedes encontrar en otra parte no
vas a llegar a la escuela de que aquí
está la clase experiencia o posible no
la experiencia es gratis y la tienes
todos los días si hoy te estás
preguntando y si no pregunta te lo
realmente estoy haciendo lo que me
apasiona qué es eso que me mueve que me
hace sentir que podría estar ahí y se te
va el tiempo y no importa y podrías
hacerlo gratis todo el tiempo porque te
encanta
te puedes tardar días meses años no pasa
nada
pero hazlo y no quiero que te limites
porque no hay ninguna idea que sea muy
loca se los dice a alguien que hoy en
día vive de comer tacos entonces
cualquier idea es buena si tú lo sientes
y si tú crees en ella de la locura a la
genialidad hay un solo paso y no te
desanimes si no ves resultados
inmediatos
thomas alva edison decía que un genio es
1% inspiración y 99% transpiración
nada sucede mágicamente hay que chingar
le
entonces yo los invito a que se suban a
este carrito
y que se acuerden del vino no nada más
se lo tomen la próxima vez que estén
frente a una copa de vino acuérdense que
no importa el momento en el que hoy este
día te encuentres tú no importa
eventualmente volverás a la luz mientras
tanto descubre cuáles son tus mejores
elotes del mundo gracias
[Aplausos]